you think it ended your career 100% 100%
yeah ain't had nothing doing my age and
having them to do what my style of play
it was because that's one'll come Marty
let's do it
how you doing man I can't call it since
you in my crib I'm gonna be honest
guests and go ahead a generous guess yo
everything going right for me real quick
oh yeah but everybody talk noise 2016
year with the coats that's the same year
Colin Kaepernick took a knee to protest
police brutality and social injustice
you took in me explain to me how that
season played out your story we are in a
team in room and Coach Pagano gets up
and says look guys I know you guys I
want to do something I don't want you
guys taking it neat what don't take me
like what you mean I think me it's like
well guys look we go out on the football
field about football I say so bad and I
turn around to some of the guys and I
suppose it almost like so when it's
about leukemia and your council it's
cool but when it's about police
brutality and social injustice it's not
cool
you know what I'm saying and I told a
couple Connor that you know I just like
made that stuff I'm telling you straight
up that's [ __ ] you know it's it's
you know football is bigger than bigger
than what's going on outside no it ain't
how about respecting the guy that's
getting murdered and killed by police
officers and not saying that all fully
surface too bad but you get song they
get they get a little power in the hand
and then appeals to power I have six
sons you know something like what my son
was in the car or what my son was
walking around and he gets and he gets
shot over nothing so that was my lunch
that was my thinking into it not because
oh you know it's the NFL techies do a
day when you took a knee who are you
playing what week was it week three week
four is when I took me because I
actually wanted to do more detail when
the ex my grandfather bite who served in
the Marines talked to some family
members actually was you know that was
part that was in the army had and do
they feel did they feel like and it was
there any disrespect you know and the
big thing that came out I was like no we
don't agree with it but our thing is
that's what we that's what we fought for
yeah you know and we fought for you to
serve that purpose to go out and protest
and how that freedom of speech and
everything else so week three we playing
the San Diego Chargers I can remember me
right before the national for the first
time I said to me and what's funny is
203 executive guys standing behind me
and it's like crow get up man no I told
you yeah they said you know what they
end up doing was one guy was standing
here
one guy was sitting here and one guy was
sitting here and another guy was
standing here one person even had a
tower just try to block it you know for
nobody one took a picture but they
already had took a picture and then week
four we are in London so we're playing
in London mm-hmm and they came up to me
before the games like a crow please
don't take me like man y'all better get
out my face
you know y'all not finished tell me what
I can and cannot do I got actually got
benched that game I got pulled out
halftime and then play the second half
at all why was that they say it was cuz
my plate but I was like eating about
four four I said you give up four
catches for 35 yards and then when
you're a touchdown off a turnover that
your quarterback threw come on man two
days after I took of me I get like three
or four phone calls like I'll recognize
his number so I had to answer the phones
like hey are you in the facility late
yeah why what's up Oh Chuck Pagano wanna
see you outside all right cool so the
economy gave me a sec huh you got your
PlayBook yeah that's all right cool let
me go talk to chuck so we get in there
and he goes into this whole spiel you
know hey you know we're releasing you
because our guys can help you
all right do ain't nobody health in the
back in at home say man you got a lot of
meat just tell you the truth
I want that only reason I wanted to say
really what he want to say but he wants
it I was like so I was like so wow I'm
getting really taking the knee no you
know it's not that mmm you know you just
you know we just feel like we can
healthy yeah I said man y'all ain't
finished in here just pay me three
million damn dollars sitting down the
release me and Danny talking about y'all
just getting help I said I don't even
make sense jump I said but it's cool I
said yeah I say you I said you better
get fired anyway straight like that how
do you respond to that I guess what
guess what happen whatever he got fired
him in the damn gym how do you think
your decision to taking me affected your
career how it affected a big time they
had nothing doing my age
having to do with my style of play it
was because I'm taking me October 2nd
what's my last game I got one workout
the whole entire time and I was by the
Saints in 2017 if you regret that
decision at all nope don't why should I
is that the only thing we did was give
people a voice I didn't have a voice and
it brought more attention to what really
was going on and now everyone's talking
about it but it's still no solution
because it's still going on what's crazy
about that is we got death threats death
threats really don't matter to me feels
like it but it's just like you know you
get guys that say they about something
and they want to stand for something but
it won't do nothing NFL is 75% black if
all black players walked off the field
one day what they gonna have you know
how much money where they lose if you
stand together thanks for kicking it
with us subscribe to be our to check out
more dope videos like this one